foreign
[Music]
spoilers show I'm your host Paul and
it's a return of the batch once again
now what a better way to start your
Wednesday than when a trip to a galaxy
far far away when the trailer for this
season first dropped everyone was
excited to see The Return of a certain
rookie and we finally get to meet back
up with him properly in this episode
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the Easter eggs hidden
details and also everything you need to
know about the young Wookie if you enjoy
the video please hit the thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe for breakdowns
like this every day by the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into the
bad batch
now the episode is called tribe and this
centers around getting gunji back to his
oh also I went back and forth over
whether it was gungi or gunji and in the
episode they say is Genji so so we're
just sticking with that right now back
to the title tribes also share common
goals and they need to be one which we
see throughout the episode now we start
off with a bad batch arriving on the
Vanguard this isn't to be confused with
Vanguard station which appeared during
the reign of the Sith Empire instead
this is very much a black market Hot
Spot similar to what we saw in the
Mandalorian season one the place is
overrun by axis droids and I can't see
flashes of l337 in their design even
though this is their first time
appearing in this Saga now the ship's
arrival reminded me a lot of the one
from the Return of the Jedi and the
shots of it flying in and Landing are
similar to Darth Vader showing up in
that movie but that is awesome Forge
chain codes and these are a type of ID
used in the Star Wars Universe at this
point in time several people were on the
run from the Empire and they needed to
have fake IDs in order to bypass their
them there's a lot of metaphors for the
second world war and during this time
the Germans were hunting Jewish people
much like how the Empire are out hunting
the Jedi they made it mandatory to wear
the Star of David on their arm but some
people refused to do this and they had
fake IDs created so they could slip
around them and Escape persecution we'll
talk about these more in a bit but after
Omega suspects something's off she
sneaks into the battles of the ship
which is where she comes across ganji
after creating a distraction she buys
him time to fight back which is when the
Vanguard droids come in a gunji first
debuted all the way back in the Clone
Wars episode The Gathering he was sent
to ilium with five of his classmates
where they were instructed to enter a
Crystal Cave as part of their training
this was in order to get kyber crystals
so that they could construct their
lightsabers and it's the first of many
Fallen order parallels another show came
before the game but that also had a
mission where he did the same thing on
ilium you also enter kashik in chapter 3
and we'll talk later on about how
similar things in the game also happen
in this entry now on the way back gunjan
in the group were captured by Pirates
however they managed to escape and he
finds himself in the clutches of
traffickers once more here gunji also
fought against the forces of Grievous
and he was there when the Jedi Temple
got bombed this was when he was under
master Terra snub who I believe showed
up in the tanks during Obi-Wan now gunji
managed to survive Order 66 and we
learned here that he was fleeing across
the Galaxy to Sanctuary this was to
kashik and he may have to go on the path
of the Jedi that we also saw in Obi-Wan
as we know the Empire do storm the
planet so the PC gets at the end won't
last very long now the entire thing with
a Jedi to me again is clearly a metaphor
for the Jews in World War II and just in
the same way that the Germans decided to
exterminate them Jedi have suffered the
exact same fate thus those that ended up
Surviving often relied on the kindness
of others like what we see the bad batch
demonstrating here the penalty for
harboring Jews was often death and the
Germans had hunted them down acted much
in the same way that the Empire does
Rogue factions would often capture
transfer them for awards and good favor
which the droids might be doing we don't
get to confirm that they're working for
the Empire and potentially he could be
sold into slavery like a lot of the
other Wookies were chain links would
provide him with a new ID that would
make him seem like he's not a Jedi and
thus if the empire ever went to his
honor and scanned his slaves then it
wouldn't seem like he'd been harboring
Jedi as the forces of Vanguard discover
gunji has escaped the batch team up with
him and he bursts at his green
lightsaber I don't know why but but
Sameer man has a green one here it just
looks way cooler than a blue one I don't
think you would have suited blue and
it's a good choice mate it's a bloody
good choice anyway they managed to
escape and gunji ends up sitting outside
omega's room at the back of the ship we
can once more see hidal Lula and this
previously belonged to wrecker who gave
her it as a gift
Omega brings gunji food and a classic
stores Cantina of what I Hope's
delicious blue milk now gunji is
standoffish initially because he's seen
firsthand how the Clones can turn on the
Jedi mindlessly They carried out all the
66 and they were able to do this because
the Jedi trusted them one minute they
were brothers in arms and the next they
were turning on their friends because
palp said so he was attempting to reach
kashyyk when he was captured and thus
they decided to drop him off and though
the Empire is in predominant year what
happens in the episode could draw their
attention and unwittingly the bad batch
may have put a Target on the planet as
they fly in we see the Luscious trees
and these are perfectly recaptured in
animation from the other times we
visited the planet now when we last saw
kashyyk in the timeline I think we were
just coming off of the back of the
battle in Revenge of the Sith the
wookies ended up harboring the Jedi and
as we know from things like solo the
population were enslaved by the Empire
black Rosanna went through this too and
if you want to learn more about him then
check out our video on the character
anyway the way it appears here is
slightly less occupied than how it shows
up later in the timeline in fall in
order when you arrive there it was being
overrun by The Imperials and also the
inquisitors during the game you start
off by hijacking an 8080 and taking out
the others but before you took to the
land to stop the Imperials this was very
much a working Uprising alongside the
rebels and along the way you encountered
some of the creatures of the planet this
included a wise shock which is the w
three ways and then shock with two K's
on the end don't know how to pronounce
it but unfortunately they don't end up
in this episode though we do get some
similar things now this happens when
they end up wandering into a part of the
forest that we see is covered in
spiderwebs this reminded me a lot of
mirkwood from The Hobbit and this
location showed up at the start of
desolation of smug however unlike the
spiders that attack the group then you
see how these ones only lash out if they
feel threatened they give them safe
passage and I also feel like the likes
of the creatures are designed to look
similar to the acclay from Attack of the
Clones now they come across the first
sign that something's a mess with a
destroyed home on the ground these were
suspended up high with the trees and the
fact that it's come crashing down shows
how the planet has fallen like the bad
batch the empires destroyed ganji's home
and we see the trandosh in slave as
moving cookie hostage across the land
this is a similar tale to the origin
story black chrisannen had and he was
captured by transition slavers when they
swarmed the planet they're using a
repurposed aat tank and these would have
remained on the planet after the
separatists swarmed it they modified the
front of the cannon to now have a
flamethrower and they stop burning the
sacred Wookie shrines reporting to
Captain venomo we see his gunji loses it
on them and he busts out the powers that
he's had to hide he frees the work he
intakes down the tank and this allows
Hunter to beat the fox
and they spend all night putting out the
fires and in the morning the freed slave
returns with backup I don't think we've
seen this giant big-eared tiger creature
before but let me know if we have now
here we meet the tribe leader Jana and
this name means god is gracious and he
answers she ends up putting her head
together with The Wookie and this is a
gesture we've seen before when Chewbacca
did it in solo with Sagwa it's clearly
something that bonds them all together
and Sago and Chewie both have just been
freed like what we see with The Wookie
here Jana also does it with gunji and he
wouldn't really spend any time with his
people before padawans are taken from
their family when they're very young and
thus they don't really grow up on the
planet that they're from now across
kashyyk we see is the trend oceans and
clones discover the lightsaber marks
this would be a massive red flag to
alert the inquisitors and it could
explain why they take such interest in
the planet in fall in order however
venomo takes control and he wants to
capture the Jedi first he offers 100
working Pals and this goes into the idea
that they'd skin rookies and wear their
almost like a trophy Boba Fett was
presented with a Wookie palette as a
gift buyer trying to notion at the start
of his Disney Plus show and bosk was
also known for cutting them apart too
the area ends up getting swarmed and
that night the batch decided to stay and
help the wookies fight the Empire gunji
learns of their ways and he joins with
them asking the trees for help in
another Lord of the Rings parallel it's
similar to the ends going to war though
the trees don't get it themselves and
join the fight obviously automatically
though there are a lot of things that
play off each other and J.R Tolkien was
very very anti-industrialization York's
represented this and they of course
destroyed the forest made bombs and also
created things that were somewhat
factories the Imperials are very much
doing this as well with them ravaging
nature and destroying kashik so that
they can mine it for resources the
search for the wookies continue and
after throwing a thermal detonator into
the mix the natives then Ambush them I
know it's a story Trope in general but
having just rewatched Avatar I was
reminded a lot of that the animals of
Pandora also came together to take on
the humans and it felt like a similar
sort of battle with every species
fighting to protect their home I suppose
you could draw similarities with Return
of the Jedi 2 and Ewoks of course also
fought the Empire on their home planet
amongst the trees I'm sure I read
somewhere that there was a discussion
about making the ewok's home the same as
the wookies but I might be
misremembering that because I'm a
now the spiders take off venomo to a
fate and known and it's pretty
horrifying seeing this guy gets spun up
and then carried off sometimes I think
the PG stuff actually has worse deaths
and if they just kill them outright
anyway the next day there's a big
celebration with Omega and gunji bow
praying to the tree Hunter realizes that
the wars strip them of their childhood
and he hopes one day for a future where
kids can live without conflict it's a
poignant way down the episode and this
was also one of my favorite episodes of
the season so far I love seeing what the
Empire has done in the galaxy and it
shows why the group themselves are so
important plus it's great in the show
ties in with the Clone Wars and Jedi and
I did have a lot of fun obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts though so
comment below and let me know we are in
a competition right now and giving away
wakanda forever the three subscribers on
the 15th of February but all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and comment below
with your thoughts on the episode we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now save that to
you and message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want to be able to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of The Last of Us which will
be linked on the screen right now lots
of things to talk about in the new
episode it's linked on screen there go
check it out and I'll see you on that
one if not thanks for saying through the
video I've been poor you take care
yourself peace
foreign
[Music]